si hubiera sales partido un nuevo
escenario que agrega atención y
certidumbre al país andino es que el
diario de consejo nacional electoral ha
suspendido el pleno que estaba previsto
a realizarse a partir de las 6 de la
tarde ha dicho que se suspende por
razones de operatividad recuerda que las
propuestas presentadas por los
candidatos debe hacer un reconteo en 16
provincias del país y del 100% de la
provincia del guayas debe ser aprobado
por el pleno del consejo nacional
electoral a pesar de que existe un
informe esto no ha sido aprobado
inclusive no se ha dicho si se va a
confirmar las propuestas de reconteo y
el porcentaje de votos que debería
realizarse según proponen los candidatos
cuál es el escenario bueno las
organizaciones indígenas se han
manifestado durante todo el día de hoy
ellos han convocado movilizaciones a
partir de las 12 de la noche para lo que
han dicho tomar vías vigilias y espacios
públicos en respuesta a sus propuestas
del consejo nacional electoral de igual
forma esto ha generado algunas
reacciones principalmente porque el
candidato guillermo lazo se ha
retractado en una carta publicada en la
red social 'twitter' donde aseguraba que
esto debe estar aprobado por el consejo
nacional electoral y no debe tomarse
como una imposición
de un solo candidato a realizar un
reconteo de los votos de igual forma
tenía existen reacciones por parte del
candidato árabes en torno a la visita
enmarcada en un acuerdo de cooperación
penal entre el gobierno de colombia y
ecuador de el fiscal del vecino país
para presentar un informe al ecuador
donde se estaría presentando archivos
del informe
uriel uriel ex integrante de la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación en
nacional donde en este informe estaría
involucrando un supuesto financiamiento
por parte de la ln a la campaña del
candidato andrés árabes financiando 80
mil dólares al candidato del correísmo
ya al candidato ha rechazado este tipo
de información y ha dicho que se trata
de una campaña sucia en su contra para
desprestigiarlo